what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends yep
hey hey hey everyone welcome to the very
first episode of the unwax podcast with
your host
sophia and sistine stallone we are
really
really excited that this is finally
happening it's been a long time in the
making and
it's here yeah i feel like uh before we
get into it actually
i'd love to give a little shout out to
producer will who
is gonna sort of pop in every once in a
while
give some male perspective yeah
unsolicited male advice
yes we love it so if you hear that
mysterious man coming in
that's will now we're really excited to
be here this has been
a very long time in the making
everyone's doing a podcast we thought
hop on that bandwagon yeah everyone's
doing it so why not join the chaos with
it and
i think it's also covid has given us a
good amount of time to actually
develop this really write good content
and
i think it's just it doesn't even seem
real right now that we've
come together yeah and i think you know
with staying at home in the pandemic
it's very scary time
we thought this podcast would be really
fun just to get your mind off of it
you come here for a good laugh we're
here to learn with you guys
bring on exciting new guests every week
it's going to be a new topic new subject
it's always going to be kind of all over
the place but we're sexy dating to
business to
so maybe we'll bring on a wizard yeah a
wizard
why not sistine's been really adamant i
get about getting yeah on here so
hopefully we get that
but i actually think it'd be good to
kind of right off the bat we should
introduce each other
like i would like i was going to say
let's introduce like me
and you do you but i think i'll i'll
introduce who you are all right
so this is my sister sistine she's aka
t-bird aka tina she has a lot of names
um she is i would say people are
intimidated with you on the outside
but when you get to meet you like you're
just super cool right off the bat
you're hilarious you have dry humor
you're easy like as
[ __ ] to hang out with everyone loves you
when you first meet you but
you're also brutally honest but you have
the biggest heart
ever she lets in all the stray dogs
cough cough her exes
that doesn't deserve her love um
but you can we're starting early oh we
are gonna start off early and you can
either find her
at the gym finishing her two hour
strength training workout
or in the cooking or in the kitchen
cooking her scones i have one-fourth cup
of sugar
that is quite the introduction blazing
already come on oh my god coming in hot
i had to i was thinking about it i'm
like if i was going to introduce you
like what would i say
and yeah i think that pretty much
something pretty much sums it up you
forgot to mention i'm 22.
oh she is 20. i'm 22. but it's fine
so i'll introduce you i guess sophia
you're 20 turning 20
turning 24. on the 27th
baby yeah we should have a birthday
episode did you ask if i turned 25
sorry um i would say sophia in our
relationship she's definitely
like an overbearing mom and she will
give
her opinion which is so brutal
and sometimes mean and you don't want to
hear it but it's the right one and she's
always right she has the best
gut instinct intuition she says that
she's funny but she's kind of not funny
so if she
says a joke maybe just like laugh will
like like like help her out sometimes
you know
you know yeah i take it back no no let
me finish
um sophia is definitely a great person
in a relationship
how how she is in life she kind of puts
into the friendships and relationships
and
with every aspect of your life you're so
kind she's a bookworm
she is nurturing she's like mama bear
and we think that's why this podcast is
going to be so much fun because
yes we're sisters we look alike but we
could not be more different of people
it's like the ying and the yang the
devil and the angel on your shoulder
yeah you should even see the ways that
we come downstairs when we dress
i'm usually in like a little white
frilly dress with heels and susan comes
in with like
a black crop top and like this crazy
yeah i look like 12 year old boy
yeah like a dominatrix and i look like
i'm going to church
so it's sweet it's a good it's a good
hot potato you know we're gonna we're
really excited to learn
and grow with you guys and talk to you
and that's definitely what i want to do
with this podcast i
haven't really used any of my social
media platforms to
reach out or talk to people so slide in
the dms
i want to hear from you guys i want to
try to answer as many of you as i can
if you have questions if you have advice
that you want
us to answer we were going to try to
thinking of you know doing an
unsolicited advice segment
so write in even if you just want to say
hi i'm lonely hi me too
call in and we'll talk to you if you're
lonely we'll give you some
little t but i wanted to also do our
social plug so where you can find us so
before we get started in the episode
make sure you subscribe to follow us on
unwax podcast on spotify apple podcast
and youtube
where you can watch us not only just
listen to us you get to see our faces
rate us review us nice please don't be
mean
please give us all the good ones um you
can follow us on
our socials and on wac social unwaxed on
instagram and twitter and of course you
can find
me and sassine on instagram and facebook
and twitter just sistine stallone and
sophia
that was a long one you know i was
probably the one i was worried about
because i know we have to do all those
plugs in
no one wants to hear them all the time
so let's get it out there so
i'm really excited for today's episode
and today's guest
um i'll give you guys a little teaser
right now
we are going to do a breakup boot camp
for you guys this is something
sophia is really bad at breaking up i'm
extremely bad at is breaking up so
our guest is going to hopefully drop
some knowledge some wisdom on us so
lace up your boots zip up your jacket
we're going into battle
we got our energy drinks in hand we're
ready to go let's bring her on
okay you guys we are back with a very
special guest
i would say she's probably the living
version of what it means to be unwaxed
in the way that she is real no no wait
wait
i know i hope you are unwaxed i really
do down there
this is what i mean she's just like
you're so wrong and that i mean you're
100
yourself you're real you're all natural
on your platforms you are a blogger
the russian mean queen and the genius
behind the account
daddy issues which has over what like
4.3 million
yes subtle flex no problem and you have
the hilarious podcast
too tired to be crazy we have violet
benson
who is killing the hair game today and
we are definitely jealous that we didn't
think of it first
first of all i'm not killing the hair
game second of all i couldn't start
like i couldn't help but start laughing
when you're like on wax i was like
when have you seen my vagina i don't
know what you're talking about
i went into a google rabbit hole so i
found some i found some
first of all i'm lasered that's a good
laser we love lasers
it's not working for me though
everything's growing back i don't know
if i'm consistent enough
oh that happens to me too but like that
when the hair grows back after you've
been lasered forever ago
it's like it's still really thin so just
so easy to get rid of that's true
it just hurts it just hurts so yes
i'm so excited to be on this unwaxed as
an unlocked gal
on show perfect just lasered thank you
for having me and i'm bored
so excited you guys are also going to be
in my podcast so this is going to be
really fun
we're doing super excited so right now i
feel like
sophie and i constantly go back and
forth with the idea that being in a
relationship during quarantine
is kind of the move yeah
are you currently single um i'm
currently a hundred percent single i
feel like i haven't dated anyone in like
two weeks
so that's kind of a record what about
how do you date
like what does that mean for you for
dating is this long term is this
a month fling i feel like um
it's weird because i'm so loyal so i'll
talk about being loyal
so when i do really like somebody i'm
100 to them but then i have the i'm so
extreme i feel like everything i've done
with my personality is so extra that's
like even when it comes to dating i
don't know how to do it normally so it's
either like i'm only dating one person
i'm obsessed with them and i'm like
you're my person they're like no i'm not
and i'm like yes
you are hello love me you love me
it's either that or it's completely
opposite i'm dating like
talking to like six guys at the same
time i can't keep up with their stories
i like genuinely don't care they're all
like send me flowers i don't even touch
them
then i like yourself like me right i
like will ghost them it's like and i'm
like i don't get what's your favorite
kind of relationship the one type of
dude you're talking to
the ten or the six at a time i prefer
talking to one guy at a time like i
don't have
the time to talk to a bunch of other
guys and it's always like you know
there's always that one guy you like the
most
and then you're just like damn i hate
that i have to talk to these other five
guys because i don't even care about
them
but it's like you have to talk to all of
them so you don't get too obsessive over
that one guy that you like
that's so interesting i've never thought
about it that way
i mean i'm single now i'm kind of
getting over the fact that i've been
single for so
long and i only want a boyfriend just to
drive me to like my eye appointments
because i'm a horrible driver
like do you want a boyfriend right now
are you just kind of like i like just
being single and talking to a bunch of
guys
um especially what am i even talking to
any guys right like right now no one
zero and how is that honestly i'm so
busy with work that i don't care but
it's also been like two weeks
so i'm sure if i got like bored enough
there's somebody to talk to but
i actually was thinking of the same
thing with a quarantine in dating i
couldn't tell if that's like a plus for
people if i should be jealous
somebody that has a boyfriend or if i
should be um
like relieved i don't have that because
i was thinking like about i saw some
girls who got boyfriends around
quarantine i was just like
ugh they're so lucky like that guy has
to stay around now look at this one he
can't leave him
there's nowhere to go he's so lucky like
i'm so jealous like wizard together and
then i'm like
but would i really want somebody to only
be with me because there's nothing
better
to do because they're like i would
rather not have and especially when
people get broken up with during
quarantine it's literally saying
i don't want not just you i just don't
want anybody like you i don't want
someone else i don't want you like
especially during quarantine because
it's like you're alone
you also feel like maybe you have to
settle because there is no other option
and normally you wouldn't pursue that
person but really i do want to ask you
because
we are doing a breakup boot camp episode
because i'm terrible at breaking up i
know sophia is terrible at breaking
i would love to know how you are maybe
you could give us some insight
some knowledge um and like what what's
your process and i know it's different
for
you know a year relationship versus like
a two-month relationship
but maybe middle ground like how do you
how do you break up with someone
well i'm really bad at breaking up okay
so like no one could help anyone
so like me dumping some but no i'm
saying going through the breakup like um
afterwards dealing with it and loving
yourself again i'm great at that
but i feel like as much as i give advice
on um
breakups i feel like i can come up i can
i'm really bad at breaking up with
somebody like i almost sometimes rather
somebody dump me then i dump them i
absolutely agree with that because for
me she's been with me
a couple times from my breakups and i
don't think i'm able to actually get the
words out and by the end of the hour
discussion they're like i really just
didn't understand one word because
you're studying that doesn't make any
sense doesn't make any sense i almost
wish they were cheated on me so i had a
legitimate reason no or literally or
i'll break up with you three months ago
and so by the time i come up to you and
talk to you i'm almost so
blank and so calm that they're like
you're psychopath
because you have no emotion i wish i
could be like that it's a virgo thing
i'm like really good at being practical
and putting things in boxes
i'm not see i i get emotional with them
like i'm either super over emotional or
like
dead like cold see i'm jealous of people
who can break up and mean it i feel like
first
i'm upset and because i'm so bad at
communicating
like instead of being like oh we're
fighting because i feel like
a lot of times when it comes to
relationships we haven't been trained
well as well as we're trained with
like subjects i totally agree yeah so
then when it comes to breakups i
sometimes don't know how to communicate
my emotions so then when i still
want the person instead of being like
hey i'm hurting right now and this is
upset can we communicate but what's
making upset
i have no words and i feel like i just
get so wrapped up and i'm just like uh
you know what i don't want to do this
and i don't mean it i just i'm just
saying
what i'm really trying to say is like
i'm hurt come to my rescue and talk to
me but really what i'm saying is i don't
want to do this
done and the other person hears me
saying we're broken up but i don't mean
we're broken up how many times within a
relationship do you think you've like
not broken up broken up with someone so
many times unfortunately
the other person now this one is give up
after the second time
yeah like bye and then like what do you
mean i still love each other
you'll touch the next day be like are
you good me
and i'm trying to like i'm trying to
work through that like it hasn't
fully changed like as much as i think i
change i sometimes go back to my old
ways and then i
i feel so bad about myself and i'm like
really hard on myself for acting this
way but then in my head i'm like well
you know what it just wasn't my person
well do you feel bad about yourself like
during the relationship because you feel
guilty about breaking up with him or do
you feel bad about yourself
post-relationship
i think i always feel bad with myself
post-relationship that's like me
but like a lot of the time you're also
not with the right people
but i also i get conflicted in my brain
because one part of me wants to be like
well
i wouldn't feel i wouldn't feel so bad
about myself and i wouldn't
feel all these emotions and anger if
this was about during the relationship
if
if we were supposed to be together right
but then the other part of me is like
well
how do you know like if you guys just
communicated and you didn't have to do
all this so maybe that person would have
been your person
so just like a fight in my brain between
the two have you ever dated someone that
really did not do anything wrong
and then you were just like i'm really
not into this and how do you break up
with someone that you have
absolutely nothing bad you know what i'm
saying like you're just not feeling it
i know that's a hard though i hate those
because they're so nice and i just had
like i had to do that and i'm like i
there's nothing wrong with you i just
don't want to be
with you right now it's not you boo yeah
i feel like
i feel like and this is what's happened
to other people so i can give the best
explanation sometimes if somebody
doesn't want to be with you you ever
seen in movies when somebody's like uh
crying and upset and then they say like
why are you so
why are you mad at me you're the one
that broke my heart it's this weird
thing where like
that's happened to me before where i
look if a person can't let me go
and i'm i don't want to tell them that
i'm into them i'll start to get mad and
angry because i'm just like dude stop
like
why do you even still like me what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
exactly and i feel bad about that but i
feel like the way i've been able to let
men easy by me not not wanting to be
with them has been
either so far the best excuse in my
opinion during quarantine has been
i feel like i'm just too depressed to
date because like no one can be mad at
you i
i said that i use that exact one i said
it's not me no it's not you it's me
i'm just so emotionally [ __ ] up i put
it all on myself even though i don't
really think that well even sometimes
and i also like that but sometimes it is
that i know for me at one point i was
like
i'm just not at my best and i know if
i'm with you i'm just gonna make you
feel like [ __ ] yeah because i'm putting
all my problems
on to you it's almost like you're
self-sacrificing they're like but i want
to help you
yeah and you're just you're like i don't
why can't i do this together like i want
to be alone and do this because i know
that
it's almost better if i do it on my own
yeah but i feel like
but i also would like to point out that
i am somebody that has battle with
depression anxiety clinical depression
anxiety so it's not like i'm i'm using
mental health as a joke
it's not like that but it's the truth
like because a lot of times when you
break up with somebody or you tell
somebody you don't want to date them
you end up being the bad guy but like
who's going to get mad at you if you're
literally like bro i'm way i'm [ __ ]
depressed it's quarantined i'm really
depressed
like no one's going to be like oh she
sucks it's like oh yeah i get that that
makes sense no i was going through major
anxiety at the time that it happened and
i
he like he knew that and i'm like i
can't control my thoughts
because of you're not doing anything
wrong but this is just at this moment
it's going in a spiral and i need to get
like my own help and
are you that person that you can you
need to be almost alone
and have your own support team to get to
that better place or do you think you
can
use like have a boyfriend with you
during that time like are you better
alone or
like i think i can be both i think when
i was younger i
i'm still getting through like i'm still
working on myself where
i uh to not need somebody to save me
because i feel like in the back of my
head like it is this thing that i
secretly always wish there's like
somebody to always be there to save me
hands i feel like that's where my daddy
is gonna come from where i need that man
to
make me better but then i feel like as
i've gotten older i'm realizing like oh
i can make myself better and i'm just
looking for a partner not to complete me
to just be by my side
so i feel like it's really different so
that's why if i don't feel like i'm at
my best now
i can't date anyone right because i just
like i want to
because if you're not your best you end
up dating people who are a reflection of
you
so they're not their best yeah you have
to own your worth if you don't think
you're worth
that great guy and you're you just think
of yourself as worthless you're not
going to choose that when did you
when did you um did you ever have a
point of realization when you thought
okay i really don't need
this person to rely on because i always
find myself
constantly searching for validation
through the men that i date like i never
thought i was pretty until they say oh
you look pretty
or i always i was constantly changing
for them so if this person
really likes an edgy girl with like pink
hair like i would dye my hair pink for
them
or if he's like i think nipple piercings
are hot i was like do i really am about
to get
like it's just so stupid looking like
saying it out loud it's really so yeah
it's like okay it's so dumb so you said
that you
you you've grown to the to not have to
do that and feel that way anymore
how did you do that well i feel like
it's a process and you can still
backtrack that's the thing about
self-growth and you just have to accept
that and be okay with it
i mean there's still moments in my brain
where i feel like like i do have that
than weird need because my dad always
one thing when growing up with my father
is that
my sister and i would compete with each
other and she was always better at
everything because she's older
so my dad would always tell my sister
how like smart she is and how much she's
gonna succeed and my dad always just
told me
i'm pretty so i feel like in a weird way
that's right
like i feel like i've worn makeup around
my dad until like my early 20s like
every time i would see my dad i would
just be like i want to be beautiful for
my father
and i didn't realize how subconsciously
was going into my relationships too so
like at one point like i had this on and
off boyfriend for like
seven years and i kid you not whatever
moments that we were together
it doesn't matter how long we're
together i would then shave my whole
body every single day because like
i need to be fully smooth for him like i
always have to be beautiful
and like no matter what i did it wasn't
enough because he was still cheating on
me all the time so that's
like you've had this constant pressure
perfect in what they deem is perfect and
it was never like about
what i need or my emotional self and i
feel like as again like in a weird way
like daddy she's really helped me find
myself and then also even
my two times to be crazy podcast it's
like a therapy for me
because a lot of times when i listen to
the advice i give by um the followers or
the guests or whatever
i'm actually giving advice to myself so
it's been like a whole journey of
self-growth so people whoever is
listening right now
they shouldn't be hard on themselves
because they can't expect like no one no
matter how
even like gandhi he didn't wake up every
day loving himself
like it's still uh you can wake up and
you can hate yourself that day and the
next day you wake up and
just as long as you know tomorrow's a
new day and you're going to try again
so i feel like with that with men it
took me a while to be like okay what do
i want what about me
and i noticed that like i just feel
silly because i i noticed a lot of these
times where i just want to be beautiful
these men suddenly have to backtrack and
be like wait
wait are they even good enough to be my
boyfriend like why am i so focused on
how i can make them be
like how i can be their perfect
girlfriend like are they even good
enough for me and the minute i take a
step back and i try to see
then i'm like wait that guy's not even
good enough for me like why do we even
care
and even if your friends are telling you
that they're like that guy's not worth
it
and then you have to seriously realize
that to yourself and then you can't
convince anybody to see
what you can't see yeah until you are
able to admit it i had a guy that i
dated the like
for i had a guy that i did it was
beginning of the year like
so quarantine has helped me like find
myself a guy that i dated and like
my friends forced me to write a pros and
cons list about him because he was like
that terrible like just not as a person
just for me as a boyfriend to
rationalize it yeah the
the cons was like a page and a half and
then the pros was like
five lines and the pros were like he
drives me around i don't like driving
that was literally always my number one
just to drive me he's nice to me he
compliments me and i really like that
um he likes to be home a lot just like
me some like like those were like the
pros and the cons were like
my dad cried when he found out we're
dating like he can't he can't get his
penis up
he hasn't really we're not he's a
problem we're not having sex
he's an ex-drug addict he doesn't have a
job he still lives at home like all of
this
and then i wrote the list you know
listen to my friends the next day i
texted the guy
a paragraph about why he's my person and
then he was like i am not
oh my wait so after you see it
in writing you still think
oh it's a you know what but i don't
fault you for that because i
am the same way i will constantly be
making excuses for these
men and i'm like oh you know you you
are hooking up with this other girl
because because i
kind of complimented her but and i made
it look cute that was basically my fault
i like i apologize when i break up with
people
even though it's there i'm like no no
it's not
me it's you and so i completely agree
with working yeah so i feel like from
that the beginning of the year but i was
also
in a low place mentally and that's why i
was attracting somebody else that wasn't
on my
level right now i finally reworked on
myself
like i'm in we're in the middle of the
year towards the end and suddenly now
when i've dated other guys
they literally no one's even touching me
we're going to first day i don't even
kiss on the first date
they're sending me bouquets of flowers
we have this argument because i i'm
always like the one that i
liked too but now i've stopped because
she told me to stop doing that
kissing is fine but i think like the
more i'm learning is like holding off on
sex it's probably better as much as like
i want to say tell girls like bang
whatever you want it whatever
actually like you get you just get so
like confused after you sleep with
somebody even if you're not an attached
person
it's it's your body like hormones for
women it's it's a
physical thing where women have exactly
you release something that becomes more
attached to that person
and guys are the complete opposite yeah
guys see thinks clearly after they have
sex
post not clarity yeah so that should be
the title of the episode
so like so yeah now it's like the guys
they send me bouquets of flowers and all
that
and i'm just really confident they
always love how confident i am and now
it's more me looking really quick like
wait hold on
do i do we share values like at this
point it's not like well he's nice to me
he compliments me
[ __ ] the compliments i can compliment
myself right do we share the same values
oh wait me and this guy like i believe
in god
and i want a guy that i'm dating that
believes in god too and i used to think
that was silly but now i'm like why
can't i just find somebody why would you
have to change
your standards and your beliefs for
someone else just to love me
it's silly yeah so taking it back a
little bit
just because i want to sort of go back
to composing
a breakup because we all agree we're not
good at it are you the type of girl that
does it
via text on the phone facetime in person
what's the easiest for you and what's
also the worst one
okay the best okay
so if i'm giving advice to girls about
boys being trashed and how they should
break up with them i would tell girls
a man should break up with you face to
face especially if you guys have been
together for a long time it's an
uncomfortable conversation but that
is the gentleman thing to do if he does
it in
facetime because you can't see each
other that makes sense too
if it's via text that's he's trash for
doing that
i mean i shouldn't do that that's trash
i agree okay
now she's like i've had to
standards here you need to do what you
need to do to get through the breakup
so whatever we're sending you a snapchat
message
whatever is the easiest for you like
that's what you needed to do to heal
baby girl
and like i got your back send a gift it
doesn't
be your word for you yeah i think that's
easy that's the difference for girls and
boys so like
so that's what i would say so yeah with
the girl
i am it's just so awkward for me to do a
breakup but like also
all the guys i've broken up with has
only been men i've dated for like
two weeks so that's why right i'm sure
if i can go back in my
real breakup of somebody of a couple of
years and yeah i would probably want to
do a face to face but
i can't relate because i usually was the
one to get dumped
because i would just stick around
forever because i'd be like no we can
make this work because i
need it yeah so you're someone that
likes to give second third fourth fifth
chance
uh yeah i used to not now but now when i
see somebody's not compatible with me
it usually tends to be in a text which
is not the best way but like we haven't
gone out for long enough and i just it's
i'm overly honest so the text is the
only way i can
probably spare their feelings i think it
is really dependent on how long you've
been going to that person because i know
that
when i was going out with someone for
like two years the first time i did it
it was over the phone
and it was really bad it was really
dirty and i'm
i i was like i am apologize sorry for
that because sometimes it's hard to face
the music in the moment
and i but i do have to say it almost
softened the blow in a way because i
already knew what i was getting into and
he kind of knew what was coming up so i
guess there was a preparing for that but
if you've been talking to someone for
like a month or a couple weeks i don't
think it you don't really need to be
face to face like over coffee going
hey um i don't have any deep emotions
for you
anymore like this isn't going to work
it's i don't think it's necessary
i have a hard time like doing that
because like recently i tried to break
up
coco break up with somebody we dated for
like two weeks or whatever three weeks
and like it was in a text and i feel
like i was just trying to say like i'm
just i just feel like i need to focus on
work
i'm not looking for anything right now
and then i felt so bad that i continued
a quote-unquote friendship so then it
felt like i had to break up with him a
few times in person
right then i feel like in the way that
didn't help
anyone because i just kept breaking up
with them
yeah because i wanted to spare his
feelings so
i feel like i feel like over time
whether you're getting dumped or you're
doing the dumping as cliche
as it sounds it's sort of a learning
experience every time and you find out
more about yourself more about what you
like what you don't like what you need
et cetera i want to take it up a notch
all right
okay hypothetical we
we just broke up with our boyfriends
right like we were just we like
we actually did like we're all seeing
people no so we spoke with our
boyfriends
what are your thoughts on rebound sex
or breakup sex or make up sex
um it depends the kind of person that
you are
so i personally can't do breakup sex
like a rebound sex because i just get
attached to the men of the guys inside
of me i'm like i love you we should do
this
while on top you're saying it you're
just like in
he inserts it in like it's about the tip
is about to go in and i'm like i love
you
it's like are we together each inch is i
love you literally yeah yeah yeah do you
want to meet my parents
is it too soon like i already chose the
ring yeah is this weird for us
like what's happening so what are we
when's the house where are we gonna go
literally yeah so i can't do and that's
why i've never really done the rebound
sex
um there's literally like only so i
haven't i'm not like if like even though
my daddy should know that like i'm just
not as promiscuous like i usually just
date guys so
i've only had like one type of like a
rebound sex person and i've treated him
shitty so
i think what people don't realize a lot
of the time that when you're rebounding
we don't even really think about the
other person so either we get too
attached to that person and then we're
trying to do a
like a fast like a 2.0 relationship
that's really fast and that's why it
starts really fast and ends really fast
yeah or we end up taking all of our hate
feelings that we're experiencing through
the breakup when we take it on that
person they don't deserve it totally
we're not really thinking about our
rebound
as like a person with feelings so as
long as like if you're able to just have
this clean sex and like
not involve any emotions of hate or love
into it like
good for you you're amazing i can't do
it so that's why i know better than to
do it so you're not the type of person
to
no i think you need to heal yeah i've
talked about one of my episodes recently
with demi burnett
about i think reasons we date toxic
people and i explained how
unfortunately people don't realize that
when we physically get hurt
um let's say you like you fall and you
you scrape your elbow
you fall in like in my example was like
you fall and you scrape your knee and
your knees bleeding and you're gonna are
like
it's broken whatever it is you're gonna
need to allow your bones to heal and to
grow back to what it is so you're not
gonna
be you're not gonna be doing more
running you're not gonna be joining
volleyball with your friends you're
gonna be home
helping your bones heal and
unfortunately we don't do the same thing
with our emotional selves no it's true
like when your heart breaks like we
don't think like oh [ __ ] like i have to
just take care of my heart right now
which means i'm either gonna stay home
and watch that movie so i can cry
because crying
releases uh stress hormones or like
how else i'm going to be kind to myself
instead of telling myself that it's my
fault we went through a breakup or like
i'm a terrible person
i'm going to be kind to myself instead
of going and jumping into another
relationship and jumping into toxic
things i'm going to avoid that because
it's up to me to heal myself
to feel whole before i go back to
another relationship so
unfortunately we just don't grow up in
school in general thinking that
our emotional selves are just as
important as our physical selves and
they are
it's absolutely and i feel like a lot of
girls struggle with the post-breakup of
how to approach it because they feel
like they either
go with their friends almost repress
everything for a couple months and they
don't even realize
how hurt they are and then they get end
up getting into like worse situations
yeah
like fortunately friendships i'm the
type of person where i
when i break up with someone that i
really did like i will internalize it i
won't tell my family about it i won't
cry about it
i'll sweep it under the rug eventually
the rug will go so high
that i trip six months later and explode
about yeah my favorite almond milk
running out and they're like why are you
crying about literal spilled milk
oh my god you're just i'm literally like
that and i'm trying to go through it
but like recently i've been so busy with
work but like this boy
couldn't hurt my feelings and i was just
like whatever i don't care
done with him stop talking to him like
cold turkey because that's how i do it
and literally like two weeks later out
of nowhere i just like
i'm like getting ready for something and
i just start bawling and i'm like what
what's happening like i have no idea i
was like oh right because i didn't take
care of my emotional self the way i
should have and like before i like i
have
makeup ready and everything i was about
to film something and my makeup is like
running down because i'm crying and i
can't stop
and it was because oh my god my emotions
are finally hitting because i was
rejected by a guy i really like
yeah or are you running and i know for
me one time i ran into the guy that i
was
dating and that's happening and i was
totally i repressed it i was like i'm
out good i'm like feeling good i think i
lost too much like weight because i was
sad
but i thought it was like because i'm
eating healthy i don't know what it was
it obviously it was the opposite
but i saw him out and then also boom hit
and then i started crying while i was at
that place i'm like
okay obviously i need to go home take a
bath
really think through some things like a
little bubble in it that happened to me
in halloween there was some guy another
guy like what i like so many guys
like there was a guy that i liked and
like i thought we ran into each other
and i was like
oh he's gonna see me looking really hot
while why and they end up talking
he wanted to talk about some other girl
and i was just like it's okay like we're
friends
we can be friends like you can tell me
about it and then he talks about this
other girl how amazing she is and i was
just like
how dare you dumb ass for like even
thinking that he should have told you in
the first place
so mean and i was just like i'll be
right back i went to the bathroom and i
started crying what were you dressed up
as
hopefully it was hot but i don't
remember but like everyone's knocking on
the door trying to get in and i'm like
not now
and i'm volleyballing then i clean my
makeup redo it and then i just walk out
of the bathroom like everything's fine
no one has to know
no it never happened continued partying
that is honestly the worst thing for me
because i'm out of sight out of mine
kind of girl i can't see my ex
i can't follow him anymore i can't get
his number so i have do not disturb on i
have mute on i have all of that on
do you ever maybe dive into the finsta
look at an x see what he's up to because
i know instagram and i stalk
hard oh my god i stalk so hard that when
i finish
going through my breakup because i have
a fence that when i finish going through
my breakup you know what accidentally
ends up happening which is my friends
tell me that it's not normal and they
always make fun of me for this
i end up getting over the guy i dated
and i fall in love in a weird way in a
weird
fall in love way with the new girl
they're dating so then i end up rooting
for justin
which is so weird but we're being like
more about wait i just get so happy for
her
and then i'm just like oh i hope she
finds someone better like first it's
like
oh they're not gonna work out and it's
like and then say you know
but then something changed and like
she's so beautiful do you ever develop a
friendship with that girl
a lot of times oh my god does the
boyfriend know
i'm literally friends with like all your
a lot of guys
a lot of guys that have data like i'm
friends with girls that they've dated
but i still in a weird way have no
problem sometimes going back to that
person too
and which is really kind of exciting can
i say
can i say it's better than the opposite
because there is nothing worse
than girls being rude to other girls for
dating someone that you stand past
because i know that
i've had so many friends be like oh
she's such a [ __ ] i'm like oh wait no
she's kind of pretty and kind of nice
like i don't think she's
observing it's just that's another sign
like you need to get over him where
there's an insecurity there but i mean
that's positive that you're getting to
befriend them i mean maybe it's not like
the best friends some of you friend but
then it becomes like it's not even about
the guy anymore like obviously again if
i dated somebody for years on years
that's probably different for me i'm
talking about like flings you day a guy
for like a month or two months three
months like let's be honest that's what
happens these days right
so yeah first it's like i'm stalking the
relationship and i hate him but then i
like weirdly fall in love with a girl in
the way that i'm rooting for her
and then i just think she's like the
most beautiful thing ever my friend's
always like she's whatever i'm like shut
up
she deserves the best and then i just
kind of
[ __ ] like you're like what the [ __ ]
yeah i really keep stalking the girl and
i forget about the guy
and then eventually i obsess over a new
guy so then i forget about her but like
like okay one time this is so crazy
one time i stopped i was like stop
dating with this guy
he was literally a sociopath like he's
the he's one of the few
usually i can say nothing but good
things about people i've dated in the
past even if i don't
feel it like i think it's important i
think it's mature to be a positive
outlook but there's this one specific
guy that i genuinely think he was
hurting so much inside that he's like
kind of a sociopath
um that he's like the only person
sometimes i bring up randomly and i say
that he has a
micro penis which he did but like that's
unfortunate
that's well that's why he's probably so
angry all the time but like
the point is that he like [ __ ] up my
head so much when we stopped talking
because it didn't even make sense and
you were so like up and down
that for it it took me a second to pick
myself back up after it because all of
his emotions like i
i took him you internalized him yeah he
had so many emotions i
kept taking them anyway the point is
that i at one point as we were going
through about to end it i started to
stalk his ex-girlfriend because a lot of
times you talk [ __ ] about her which is
completely disrespectful by the way
like and i'd agree with that yeah so
then one day i'm going to get my nails
done and i see this girl sitting there
getting her nails done and i literally
with the smile
thinking that girl is my friend start to
walk towards her and i'm like
oh my god tell me
ash i see her face go like you know
we're like huh uh oh
something in my brain go oh my god oh my
god like uh abor
a boy you don't know her you don't know
her so i literally then like
changed my face and then walked past her
to a wall
smooth just stand in the corner like
disciplining yourself but you're like oh
yeah
that was the best time she sees a ghost
in the corner we're gonna just grab my
phone like yep
hey what's up imagine a majesty
a girl say hi to you walk to a corner
just stand and face the wall on the
phone she doesn't have a phone she uses
a finger phone
she's real sorry yeah i'll call you
right back the numbers look good
oh my god because that's how much i
like stalked this girl thinking she's
like my friend and i wanted the best for
her
i didn't realize she wasn't even my
friend that is the problem with social
media today because
i will do the same thing i will look at
a person's profile for so long and then
i'll see them in person like the other
day i was at the gym
i see this instagram model which she has
an incredible audio i'm always looking
at her page she's so pretty
and i go up to her while she's mid
workout i'm like what's up my name is
christine like
and she's like hi i was like oh so sorry
but i hate when girls are not nice like
i feel like that bothers me when a girl
is like
okay so like i've had those yeah and i'm
like why do you have to be so mean
like i'm a fan of yours yeah i'm a fan i
like her
okay isn't like a sign of threat she's
not coming up going like
nice workout like [ __ ] yeah i don't
know i said your outfit looks cute and
she's like
it's so hot out like what well she
probably doesn't have a personality
maybe that's right there you go
well at least your friend says you get
to stop girls i get blocked by every guy
that i stalk because
how do they know because well say the
names i'm not going to say any names no
no
i'll say like your account i had like
cherry stevens i had
remington remington this is what how's
crazy we used to watch my ex would do a
live stream with his 200 followers i
don't know why he'd be online
all the guys we go out with are like
they have a couple hundred followers so
they could easily see if something like
creepy so we have running shoes
we have remington commenting non-stop
on her and actually he'll give
brotherhood yeah well now if he watches
this you definitely
hey friend um but yeah i know i
i end up just kind of [ __ ] up because
i'll watch the story too many times and
then i'll get blocked and then i get so
embarrassed because i'm like
they caught me and then i delete it
because i just and then i remake one but
yeah
i had to start fresh because i need to i
can't keep doing it over so it's really
talking
yeah the guys i date now uh like
especially this year have all been guys
who
are not in that like entertainment so
they all have like a
like followers 200 flowers but like if
anything i feel like it's made my life
easier because then when we
break quonko break up i can just
unfollow them and they're private so
like i have
i have no choice but to get over them
because i can't creepily like they know
my face yeah
yeah i can't just randomly follow them
because they'll know they're not going
to add how many fences do you have
no i just have one but if i change the
name and so i'm not going to say
i mean if i say the name of it then i
have to change it i already i really
like the name so
okay keep it keep it do you have any
followers on it it's just zero um like
my mom and like a few close friends
i have like 30 friends on it oh that's
too suspicious
yeah my zero zero photo zero that's
creepy
that is no but i have this sexy like
cute girl is my picture that's not me
to get dms from guys being like hey cute
no i had a girl with cherries
she had like this beautiful red hair
like glasses and i'd literally get dms
from people like this is really awesome
why would you say yes like hi to someone
that has absolutely no following
absolutely no photos i think that
there's no shame in stalking
and i hate when people judge you for it
like why is it a bad thing because i
guarantee the guy is looking at your
profile just the same
i kind of wish sometimes instagram
didn't exist at all because i really
just don't want to know what they're
doing
i don't know why i don't want to know
where they are that's what i loved about
facebook like when you have facebook
when you're younger if you block
somebody
it blocks you from their account too i
mean unless instagram has changed at
this point but like it blocks you like i
remember
years ago like my first boyfriend when i
was 17 and we have facebook
i blocked him in order for then for it
wasn't about him not seeing my stuff it
was about me not seeing his stuff so
once i blocked him like i couldn't see
anything i feel like with instagram now
it's different like if i block you
you can't see my stuff and it's like no
i want you to see my [ __ ] i want you to
cry about it right
i just don't want to see your stuff i
never want guys to not stalk me because
i feel like every time i get a breakup i
almost glow up 10 times more because i'm
trying way harder to be like
great on instagram even though my life
is like falling apart behind i think we
should bring back facebook there was no
better feeling
me in middle school getting a little
message notification from a boy and
they're trying to like talk to you
and oh yeah that was the cutest thing
like a i am or ask fm
i don't even know how to use facebook
anymore i know i don't i keep getting
i keep getting disabled because someone
says that they're impersonating
or i'm impersonating me and someone from
iran
keeps reporting me it's the same one the
same person person
just one person has like a fake account
of you and just doesn't want you
to exist that's great that's a bummer
okay so i think that we should wrap up
the episode just leaving someone with
just a little bit of something that
could take away because i don't know if
anyone learned anything
any like breakup final advice for girls
that are going through it or
are thinking about it okay final advice
if you're going through a breakup
would be to a delete his number
if you need to block him that's what you
need to do for yourself don't think
about how he's feeling
and if you're trying let's say you're
going through a breakup and your mindset
is to get him back the best way to get
him back
is by silence that's what people don't
get it's not about begging for him back
it's not about being like hey like did
you see the weather today
no keep your mouth shut for two months
i'm not kidding absolutely it's a
two-month rule you keep your mouth shut
and the guy starts to wonder after a
month minimum
two months maximum if after two months
you don't hear from him he just never
gave a [ __ ] about you and that's okay
just keep going move on because he's
moved
after two months he's going to be
wondering what are you up to don't post
sac quotes that's really pathetic
it's not i'm just saying it's true
that's what men think i'm not saying
it's pathetic for you like it's
i love sac quotes but men look at it and
they're like ah she's hurting
right it makes them feel good don't get
like continue your life as if nothing
ever happened and it's going to make
them
wonder if you ever even cared about
about them even if they dump you
the minute you're just like all right
and you just keep going you don't you
don't give them a whole
like essay about why you guys should
have been together like forget that
just say okay accept it and even though
if you're crying every night
do it cry but there's no way he should
know about it so
when he's seeing it from outside it
looks like you're posting the same way
as if everything's fine you're not
reaching out to him because you deleted
his number
and he's gonna want you back and
hopefully by the time
two months pass you're not even going to
want him at this point because they
always come back when you're already
over them
yep silence drives the man crazy that is
the
ultimate there's a saying or maybe i
said the saying i forget but there's a
saying that says or i
i say this is that um what was it
[ __ ] i forgot like no like distance
makes a heart grow fun no it's almost
like
no words are the best words if you want
to teach a man something about like if
you want to teach a man a lesson
then like oh actions don't teach a man
it's silence it teaches a man something
like that i love that
but that is the daddy that is the daddy
issues quote right there yeah
we're pointing you well thank you very
much for coming on
you guys it's so good really i'm so
jealous of this episode i'm going to
steal it steal it
steal it come on ours again because you
honestly are you exceeded my expectation
yeah
you're so excited i get that so much
thank you i'm kidding no no no
we're gonna be you're very easy to talk
to you're so nice like
honestly you know you always have like
an expectation when you're about to meet
someone for the first time and it's like
it's really nice when people kind of
just like exceed that yeah yeah
and thanks for being on our first
episode of our thank you for having me
congratulations thanks
do you want to put in your plug or
anything oh yeah yeah just for fur
you guys don't forget to check out my
personal instagram which is viola benson
my meme account which is daddy issues
underscore and then my podcast who try
to be crazy is on
every thursday we're on instagram and
we're on also on every channel that you
can listen to it
it's from a bunch of fun guests like
these two sisters they're going to be on
my podcast too
and it's also just like seoul episodes
of teaching you how to love yourself how
to be a boss [ __ ] at work
and blah blah blah so check it out i
love you guys and thank you so much for
having me thank you
okay bye from all of us here at the show
thanks for staying on wax
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at unwaxed podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week